peu à peu
[Musique]
bonsoir soit le cas
bonsoir
[Musique]
vous qui avez entre 10 et 15 ans quel
sera le programme de vos dernières
séances dans 20 ou 25 ans je suis sûr
que vous serez content de retrouver des
routes film d' aventure qui vous aimez
bien maintenant comme indiana jones mad
max oui comme moi je suis content de
retrouver les héros que j'aimais bien à
l'époque et qui s'appelait il va nouer
l'histoire barthen je m'identifiais ses
personnages je jouais à ivanov et j'ai
joué à robin des bois et je m'identifie
aussi aux acteurs le roi des acteurs à
l'époque c'était clark gabe le jeu
c'était tellement terrible claque bonne
pour moi que dès que je fermais les yeux
j'avais l'impression que je tirais de
fleurs dans autant en emporte
c'est ça qui est formidable c'est qu'on
peut rêver qu'on est un autre personnage
est un acteur vous rêviez d'être une
star antivaleurs erika d'amour
passionnée jury
je rêvais de faire du cinéma avec les
copines ont fini monde gt après midi par
youtube
il aurait détenu dans les boîtes figurez
vous qu'on n'allait pas l'école mais
jeudi après-midi le même préféré comme
le jeu des buts et enfin aujourd'hui
nous allons voir le rendez vous des
hommes comme un symbole c'est un film
d'edward mitric 2009 155 rue avec clarté
je suis allé voir michael réunis et ça
se passe en chine
et vous savez je connais munitions
maintenance et d actualité et vous aller
gêner tout le monde si vous restez poule
à le payer
réalisé par chuck jones que la dernière
séance vous propose pour les mois à
venir
jack jones c'est un maître à penser pour
bip bip et le coyote on peut résumer les
scénarios très simplement
c'est un coyote qui poursuit un world
runner animal très célèbre dans les
déserts américains pour l'attraper il
fait appel à une société qui livrent des
pièges très compliqué à monter soi même
en quelque sorte c'est un kit 2 1 et
immanquablement sa foi et comme le dit
si justement chuck jones le coyote est
le pire ennemi du coyote
c'est un vieil adage chinois bon alors
maintenant je vous ai choisis un western
personnellement mais pas n'importe quel
western s'est-elle perdido d'euros
berhad reach vous souvenez-vous de
robert aldrich à la dernière séance
ah oui parce que dernièrement nous avons
vu un film qui s'appelait trahison
athènes et puis le monde est beau film
comme les douze salopards et attaque
j'aime les histoires ambiguë où les
[ __ ] sont séduisants où les héros
sont pas toujours blanc blanc alors là
on est gâté parce que c'est rock hudson
qui est un héros mou nous mais attention
c'est le rôle qui veut ça parce qu'en
europe c'est un garçon solide et n'a pas
toujours été comme ça enfin pas souvent
et il n'a pas tourné que dans des
mauvais films non plus des nuls c'est
vrai mais il a été franchement bons
comédiens dans les mélos de douglas sirk
le secret magnifique la ronde de l'aube
écrit sur le vent oui où il joue avec
l'héroïne d'elle perdido d'ortie malone
tordo mais vous ne pensez qu'à ça les
rares fois où je pense oui mais surtout
ce pareil sauf mon père
dorothy malone déjà tout petit c'était
un bébé modèles et elle a reçu un oscar
et puis vous la connaissez bien parce
qu'elle a été la vedette de la série
high tone plus bas c'est kirk douglas
qui produit ces aldridge qui réalise etc
dalton trumbo qui a écrit le sujet je
vous rappelle que dalton trumbo c'est un
très grand écrivain
bon c'est parti pour l perdido en
anglais jeu là ce sont 7 le dernier
crépuscule c'est quand même autre chose
j'ai skié à vous mais vous savez que
vous parlez aussi bien monsieur eddy
sert arracher un jeune jambes